now you wouldn't believe me if I told
you but I could run like the wind blows
from that day on if I was going
somewhere
I was running what do people mostly ask
you but what would we mostly say to you
and shout out to you when they see you
oh it it they used to yell houston we
have a problem that you see all that and
they you run Forrest run that's a biggie
but now they just they just yell this
time that in Forrest Gump
the famous voice to use as Forrest it
came from a specific person young
Michael Connor Humphries who played
young Forrest Gump we were trying to Bob
Zemeckis okay maybe say hey we got a
problem on this there's Michael right
there the Sally and Sally and Michael oh
he was a very young man he's now a
veteran he's served in Afghanistan
Bob said oh we got a problem here you
have to teach this kid how to talk the
way you want to talk and I thought why
don't why don't I just talk the way he
talks right now and so we started
hanging out with him and he was from
Mississippi deep in Mississippi and he
had this he had this hard G at the end
of his if they said it wasn't thinking
it was thinking it wasn't making it was
making and said what does what does your
father do my god
my my dad it makes grace that's what he
said he said he'd make I don't
understand this Greece something you
make yes he says what do you do with
Greece well Greece goes into all
different sorts of products like what
products Oh Greece goes into lipsticks
I need to settle a little controversy
little controversy there was a picture I
are you've probably seen this it was on
the internet and in in papers and things
and it's this picture here now oh yeah
we're trying to decide if that was Bill
Murray or Tom Hanks right well I've been
doing a pale imitation of Bill Murray
for mostly works out I know that it's
not me
because I did not take that I've had a
cranial plates shift that as a medicinal
I that's not me I could make that face
[Music]
anything ever top Toy Story later
Tim Allen the voice of buzz yes time I
saw me was give me an Oscar but the
weird thing is that is so loved but
children when they see you walking down
the street they don't know there is
countless elevator rides I'll be in the
elevator in a in a mother and child will
get on and the mother will say it's
woody try to explain know their voices
recorded and the actor who is the voice
this is the actor make the kids just
don't get it at all
I said where's the vest where's the
cowboy hat you're not very tall and so I
say hmm all right close your eyes I
think a lot just just close your eyes to
[Applause]
think that one of the last things Abama
will have done in a in office is to give
mr. tom hanks the highest civilian
honour in America the Medal of Freedom
oh yeah
[Applause]
oh yeah then I'm a couple of days yeah
it's the coolest dude in the room I
don't so much of the man it's crazy
because you have had so many awards like
what does that mean
it's mind-numbing you know it's look
it's the medal of freedom which means
somehow it's funny talking about what
you're doing about with Edward Snowden
there is this look we have we have
something which is the freedom that
you're talking about and I guess it's a
look at the the work that I've done that
has both celebrated it and promoted it
and try to protect it as well so I can
look I'm with a grace Admiral Grace
Potter the scientist who literally
measured out the nanosecond her Kareem
abdul-jabbar me this pretty good spread
was quite good company yeah rubbin
elbows at the buffet the the filmmaker
Michael Moore who actually did call out
this whole election I mean he kind of
saw how he's now said and I he said that
he wants you you know I thought it was
deranged rod was not deranged right up
until he said he wants you to run as
president yeah okay all right
years of your life do it I'm not
qualified to be the president of the
three stooges fan club but you are a
recording artist oh dear well let's say
I've been forced into the studio at
gunpoint on occasion yes yes
yeah no you went all kind of hip-hop
rappy honors didn't you yes I haven't a
rap hit that haunts me for the rest of
my days yes yes this was you and and the
eniac record we were promoting dragnet a
motion picture 1987 and we sang of
course everybody can sing along look out
streebek you're just in time
we have stumbled into a major crime
she's got the girl off frightened no
that's not nice I think she is a subject
of a sacrifice buddy but first you know
we really ought to read them their
rights read them their rights weed in
their rights
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you
[Music]